as a child I really didn't know what I
wanted to do I wanted to do everything
so I really ended up trying to do
everything and I've a very sort of
checkered career I'll let you guess
which one of these lovely children is me
these are my brothers and sisters and I
think because of my interest was it was
technology it was the world around me it
was conservation gerald durrell set his
world-famous Zoo up on Jersey so I was
exposed to exotic wildlife from very age
got very interested in development and
all sorts of other things I ended up
with a fairly mixed bag of a career so
25 years in IT 17 years living in
working in 8 or 9 different African
countries running primate sanctuaries in
Nigeria doing biodiversity survey work
on Uganda doing school building in
Zambia hospital building in Uganda I
taught English in Finland did a degree
in social anthropology and it all kind
of came together the ideal job for me
was to combine all those interests and
the job didn't exist so I had to make it
and that's really what I'm doing doing
now I think I ended up at the end of all
of that dough at 2:00 in 2003 working in
South Africa in Kruger National Park and
we were looking at the time at how
mobile phone technology was starting to
emerge in rural communities now this was
7 and a half years ago it was nowhere
near it is now it's phenomenal what's
happened in the last 7 odd years but
back then people had a hunch that things
were happening and these mobile phones
that were appearing in the hands of
people earning two three dollars a day
actually might become something very
very useful this was a report that I
co-authored in 2004 one of the very
early attempts to try and document what
was going on and it was hard a lot of
anecdotal evidence a lot of lot of
hunches but I think today we've seen and
we continue to witness this amazing
revolution really that mobile technology
is bringing it also brings a challenge I
think if you if you ask people in the US
what innovation looks like it looks like
this it's like the iPhone 4G announced
yesterday it's this very high-tech very
sort of power-hungry data hungery
applications things we carry around in
our pockets and things that make our
lives easier I'm not sure if people
really stop to think whether or not we
really need i pads because we can do
most of the things that we can do on
that on a on a laptop after all the
problem with this so is if we think
about innovation in these terms we
forget that
for most of the world this stuff is
totally irrelevant it doesn't really
make any difference to them at all if
you think about places like this this is
bushbuckridge it's an area on the edge
of Kruger National Park where I was
doing a lot of my early work now iPads
and a lot of the technology where we're
roaring away with doesn't work in places
like that it doesn't work in places
where there's no internet there are
places in the world Believe It or Not
where there's no internet and and we
almost struggle to comprehend how we
would live without our Gmail and Twitter
and all these crazy social media things
that we use it also doesn't work on old
phones and and you know very old models
of Nokia phones and monochrome screens
and ones that don't don't allow you to
download apps and do all this kind of
fancy stuff and many people are still
using these phones this is quite a
modern phone in the terms of the kind of
things I see when I'm out in the field
but these phones are old and don't do
anything really really smart at all also
these technologies don't work in the
kind of places where mobile
manufacturers are having to think about
advertising their phones as tortures
because one of the main problems people
have is a lack of light at home that's
an amazing picture I took I think about
four years ago in Uganda and it looks
like a torch ad but it's you know by the
way you can also make phone calls on
this thing if you really really want to
and this is how people are thinking
about how you sell to an audience and a
market which is very very different to
the one that we live in and I think we
need to be aware as we march ahead that
this world does actually exist the the
big moment for me I suppose that there
were a couple of big moments but the
early one was doing the work in Kruger
National Park and they wanted to set up
a system to start sending messages to
the communities around the park to
re-engage them in the conservation
effort arrange meetings ask some
questions just generally start to talk
to them a little bit more and they were
starting to get phones and they said to
me can we set a system up that allows us
to send 200 texts to go up to 200 people
and you know we can do elephant alerts
as well when elephants break the fence
all that type of stuff
and I looked and I couldn't find
anything that worked in a place like
Kruger National Park everything needed
the Internet it needs lots of money need
a training and it just didn't make any
sense so that was kind of the gap and
the other part really for me was that
Kruger national parks were going to
control this system and we're not
speaking to the communities you very
quickly realized that in fact they were
the first ones who would know if an
elephant
an offense because they're in their
fields right and they don't have that
button to press the people are going to
press the button and do the alerts or
100 miles away and it made no sense so I
was thinking about where is the control
if we're building these things and we
try to think about building technologies
to help rural communities who presses
that big red button and often it's
somebody far far away and very detached
from the situation that's the wrong
button there we go so the solution for
this for me was this software called
frontline SMS this was a second aha
moment I was sitting at home watching
football with a bottle of beer one
Saturday night and I just thought about
hey you know this idea started to come
through my head and it really turned out
like this it's why not set up a
communication hub but it runs off of the
mobile phone network which exists which
doesn't require the internet so by
installing a software on a laptop you
plug in a phone with a cable put numbers
of the farmers health care workers
communities into that system you can
send them all the message and it's very
easy and it works pretty much anywhere
and and funnily enough it does work in
places like this where many many tools
weren't working because they required
things like the internet and high-tech
equipment the nice thing for me about I
think what we've done I always felt very
uncomfortable travelling around and
being seen as somebody who had all the
answers to all the problems I think very
few of us really have many answers at
all you find the people on the ground in
the communities of people that have HIV
or the farmers who are struggling they
have their own thoughts and their own
ideas and nonprofits that are working
with them and many of whom have worked
with them for a very very long time
actually know we'll have a pretty good
idea how they can go about solving these
problems
so rather than barreling in and actually
trying to take over why not give them
tools that allow them to do what they do
better they know the language the
culture the geography everything is
someone like I do not know and this is a
really really nice quote I think for me
which which sums up what the software is
allowing these people to do we provide
it we step back we let them get on with
it and the users have been pretty
bewildering got a sense when Hannah was
going through the list of the kinds of
things people are doing with this I'll
give you a few examples now but it's
it's actually staggering for me if you
actually trust people enough to do the
work themselves they actually can do
some pretty innovative things election
monitoring Nigeria Philippines Malawi
was using the Philippine elections again
this year Jews in Afghanistan I'll just
touch on that in a few minutes as well
these are local groups who wanted to
monitor and get a sense of how their own
elections went they don't want the UN to
come in and do it they didn't want
international organizations they wanted
to do it themselves Nigerians were sick
and tired of other people coming in and
doing it for them using this tool they
were able to set their own systems up
for the very very first time in 2007 and
do that in Zimbabwe it's being used to
send information to rural communities
have a completely starved of any
meaningful news or perhaps any news at
all and also gives them a voice back you
can ask them how they feel about things
what's happening in your area very very
useful when when Mugabe is flattening
people's houses and doing the slum
clearing and people just don't have a
voice and in many cases using tools like
this gives people a voice for the very
very first time people that are finding
that drugs they need to help their
children who may have diarrhea or
antimalarials going to clinics and
finding they're out of stock many East
African governments deny there's a
problem of supplying essential drugs
through clinics this is a map of places
where essential drugs are not available
the bigger the red blob the bigger the
problem this is great for government
transparency someone can go into a
clinic try and buy a drug if they can't
get it they can text in it can be mapped
and visualized and it can really change
the game really government's find it
very hard to deny there's a problem when
they see maps like that in Afghanistan
as Hannah mentioned it's being used to
send security alerts to field workers
it's been used for many years now almost
in the beginning to do that when I
blogged about this recently I was was
writing about it and I got this email
that night it was quite spooky but got
an email that night from one of the
users and to Red Cross workers have been
killed in a Taliban attack and this for
me to a drove home how crucially useful
and important a simple dumb 160
character SMS can be if it's sent at the
right time and you're in the wrong place
and it can help get you out of places
and it's kind of humbling in a way to
think that we're solving these problems
but it just shows that these tools I
think really are needed in Iraq as well
Sally Rockey using it to spread news
around the country they're the first
international news organization since
the fall of Saddam and anti-human
trafficking projects you can
bed these systems within the communities
so communities can set their own systems
up and they can control them they can
put them in their own languages they can
adapt a messaging and that's very very
empowering the mall the latest use of
this was in Haiti after 30 American aid
workers or religious group members tried
to take some children out of the country
and many of you may have heard of that
there was a lot of concern around doing
that but using this simple technology
you can embed these systems into the
communities and you can actually allow
them to control and run them pumps to
farmers there's actually some great
pumps and the exhibition around the
round the back there the design for the
other 90% exhibition which is fantastic
but farmers have expressed an interest
in the pumps give their mobile phone
number they can then be put into systems
and they can be texted when the special
offers or when there might be a
demonstration in their area or to ask
them how they got on and that's a very
nice social business use of it and these
pumps have quite a significant impact
for the farmers and in Afghanistan this
was when it was used last year to help
monitor the Afghan elections and again
these were local Afghan media groups
that were doing this it wasn't done by
any large international donor and it
gave a voice to the people this whole
thing about citizen reporting and
allowing people to actually say how they
feel about things and their own
particular experience if you marry that
with the international news you do get
this amazingly fresh and new exciting
angle on what's happened in these kinds
of events and of course elections in
Afghanistan are probably as hard as any
other place you could you could imagine
when Obama visited garner a few US
embassies used a software to text out to
communities when the radio address was
going to be on
I should probably charge the State
Department for using the software for
everyone else it's free but you know
okay and in Malawi this is a really
interesting case this is the last
example here a student from Stanford
University went to San Gabriels Hospital
in Malawi a couple of years ago and he
installed the software and this is
Alexander who's the head nurse he's
running a rural healthcare network for
quarter of a million people through that
laptop the community health care workers
hundreds of Maga phones and they
communicate through SMS through the
whole thing they're the one one to
service in their village they can ask
about information about drugs and it's
actually had a profound effect and it's
it's got a lot of attention as it
rightly should saving thousands of
dollars
unnecessary journeys where people were
traveling out to give patients
injections who had died the night before
for example silly dumb stuff but really
really essential communication which has
revolutionized the way this hospital now
delivers health care to those people
there's two doctors for quarter of a
million people so you really want to use
those resource as well it's now become
front on SMS medic which is a spin-off
organization which is now applying our
software specifically in health another
one now is applying it in microfinance
you can run a bank from a laptop now and
disperse and receive money from rural
communities and small borrowers and
lenders and another one is applying it
in bullying in schools so schools can
download complete anti-bullying systems
from the internet with all the equipment
and everything you'll need to buy from
the shop and then they can run their own
anti-bullying or bullying reporting
systems this is a world map of coverage
have no money for marketing or anything
this is viral spread users using it
doing cool things telling other people
people going on the web and downloading
it we don't get involved in any of this
stuff so these people have done it on
their own we've won a bunch of awards
and and being here is fantastic
recognition I think of the work of the
users more than anything because they're
the ones that have the stories and we've
been in the media and this isn't bad
actually for a piece of software that I
wrote in 2005 from a kitchen table in
Finland that's the view I had out of the
window had no money nothing but just had
a hunch that this was useful and I think
the message there is you do not need
lots of money lots of resources and to
know big names to actually get these
things done if you're passionate and you
find a solution you believe in and you
stick to it after maybe five or six
years it will pay off I wish it had paid
off a little bit earlier the house
quickly what's coming up next is a USB
stick version the computers a bit of a
barrier for most NGOs let's have it on a
USB stick you can go to an internet cafe
plug it in do your stuff how about
running one off a phone so you don't
need a computer at all you just carry
this messaging hub in your pocket on the
phone and we're adding picture messaging
this month which will allow farmers and
healthcare workers to transmit pictures
around the network which could actually
really help farmers and health care
workers deliver better services very
very quickly if you build these
technologies to work in these places
make sure that the bits and pieces
people have to buy are available locally
not things they have to order from very
very far away make sure they plug
together well maybe IKEA is not a great
example because I always end up with
dozens of bits and pieces left
when I try and build a table but make
sure things plug together and people can
understand how that works
make them free or cheap don't put a
price barrier up if you've brought a
technology barrier down because he's
still got a barrier make sure it can
replicate allow people to talk and share
and spread news and and basically help
each other out
forget the Internet absolutely forget
the Internet if you forget the Internet
you can do a lot and also allow them to
connect and provide online services if
they can get online to talk to each
other and to share experiences and
stories we've managed to do that too and
go outside your comfort zone so I just
love this cartoon it's a second Gary
Larson cartoon of the morning actually
funnily enough but if you're a techie go
outside your techie box if you're a
social scientist go outside of your
social scientists box I think that's
absolutely crucial and think
appropriately this book was written in
1973 and it's still as valid today in a
world that didn't exist when this book
was written and don't compete kids don't
care who vaccinators them they do want
to get a vaccination so let's work
together and genuinely cooperate and
then the logo this is a kid doing the
front listen mr. logo it's an
empowerment theme we decided through a
branding agency called Wyden Kennedy
that empowerment was a key theme this
kids doing that logo it's actually this
it's a text herbal logo back slash
forward slash which represents that that
logo and we're getting pictures of users
doing this logo which is quite random
and strange I actually have a whole load
of badges with me today if anyone wants
one of these badges they're incredibly
collectible and we have users in the UK
as well who are also doing this so we've
got something going on here and it's fun
but I think it shows a connection we've
made by trusting the users and allowing
them to do what they do and not get in
the way and interfere and I think this
go back really to the beginning and and
just think about all the innovation we
see around us in the countries that we
live in this part of the world and we
just forget sometimes I think there's
actually another world out there where a
lot of what we're doing doesn't make any
sense and the technology that we're
using does have immense power whether
it's a security alert to a field worker
in Afghanistan or whether it's a health
message to a HIV sufferer in rural
Zambia those things can be really really
crucial so let's not let's not not get
too carried away with the exciting iPad
iPhone stuff and that's maybe just pause
them
and just asked a question who are we
really innovating for thank you very
much